[Music]
we're gonna have an excellent program
here this I'm really glad I got to
moderate this one three really excellent
economists that are an historian we sort
of let him be an economist because he
took some grad grad classes in economics
as well so he's sort of an adopted
economist and what we're going to talk
about is the gold standard now this
morning you Richard Ron pointed out that
US has an enormous amount of debt in and
if you look at what's just called debt
held by the public that is the debt
that's not held between agencies that's
about 3/4 of a / three fourths of GDP
about 75% of GDP is the amount of debt
held by the public out there and there's
only been one period the United States
history when it's been above 50% and
that was during World War Two in the
Korean War so we have this very high
amount of debt relative to GDP and for
all the economics professors or people
have had economics you know what ought
to happen then is that you if you have
the debt it increases the demand for
loanable funds and that i drive up
interest rates so we should have been
seeing interest rates rising but instead
what happened is the Federal Reserve as
you heard this morning has been buying
the debt so if you think back to your
principles of macroeconomics class when
the Federal Reserve buys the debt what
does that do it increases the reserves
of banks and then when the banks have
reserves they go when they lend it out
and that becomes money and checking
accounts and then what happens is you
when you have more money relative to
this very technical economics term stuff
when you have more money than money's
growing faster than the stuff is growing
then you get price inflation right
because the the value of your currency
is going down and so the question then
happens is what do you get while
eventually you get inflation and as
you've seen the Zimbabwean dollar and
and of course you've heard stories about
that what happened in Germany after
World War one and so with it you have a
break down to the
you get a breakdown of the system
altogether so the question then is why
is that not happening now and one of the
reasons of course is that the banks
instead of holding about two billion
dollars in excess reserves which would
be normal they're holding about one and
a half trillion dollars in excess
reserves so what's going to happen when
that one and a half trillion dollars in
excess reserves moves out in a
multiplied effect throughout the money
supply is that going to create inflation
and and what are the problems with that
and so what one of the one of the ways
that economists have looked at as
restraining the ability of your
government to go out and destroy the
medium of exchange through
hyperinflation is to have a gold
standard and so what this panel is about
is the gold standard we're gonna start
out with the George Celgene dr. Celgene
is going to be he's going to sort of
give you the 20 minute version of a
history of the gold standard it's F and
I and all these papers will be on on the
website of the college and so you can
get all the full detail from that but
dr. Celgene is going to give us the the
shortened version of the history of the
gold standard and he is the professor of
economics at the University of Georgia's
Terry College of Business
his research covers a broad range of
topics within the field of monetary
economics including monetary history
macroeconomic theory and the history of
monetary thought he's the author of four
books on monetary economics including
his most recent book is good money
Birmingham button makers the Royal Mint
and the beginnings of modern coinage
it's like a great title right from
University of Michigan press in 2008
he's also written for a number of
scholarly journals including the British
numismatic journal now I learned the
word numismatic because my daughter just
got her PhD in classical archaeology and
she deals with these coins right so who
knew what numismatic means if you don't
have a daughter doing that but but
George is published in a journal dealing
with that the economic journal and the
economic history review the journal of
economic literature and the journal
money credit and banking and also
popular outlets such as the Christian
Science Monitor the Financial Times in
The Wall Street Journal
he's also co-editor of economic journal
watch which is an electronic journal
devoted to exploit exposing
inappropriate assumptions weak chains of
argument phony claims of relevance and
emissions of pertinent truths and the
writings of professional economists
please join me in welcoming dr. dr.
Selden thank you thank you Gary
thanks to Hillsdale and also to the
Durrell Foundation for giving me the
opportunity to speak to you today as the
title of the book my book that Gary
mentioned may indicate to you I'm not a
man of few words indeed I was asked to
write a 20-page paper on the history of
the gold standard for this meeting I
ended up writing what would have been 50
pages if I hadn't tried to save a little
paper by spacing it more narrowly and I
have no intention at all to of trying to
summarize the contents of that history
which are already as terse as I could
make it make them in the few minutes
that I have by the way I have 20 20
minutes so I'm going to just try to make
a few points about the gold standard
here in its in its history and what I
want to do is to confront what I think
is a popular myth about the gold
standard now Larry will confront some
other myths mainly of critics of the
gold standard but here I want to address
what I perceive to be perhaps a myth
myths relating that are more common
among people who are fond of the gold
standard the basic myth being that there
was once a time when we lived in a gold
standard paradise and it had always been
so until the fall came the fall came
either in 9 in 1933 or in 1971 or
perhaps even earlier depending on what
episode you think involved the greatest
sin and we've been paying for our sins
ever since what I want to suggest is
that this is a rather
well this is an interesting myth of the
gold standard but things are actually
much more complicated than that
and I want to start by taking us back to
the founding of the United States and
particularly by having you imagine that
you could time travel to that era armed
equipped with a Federal Reserve Note and
show the note to Thomas Jefferson for
example you could pick any of the
founders for this purpose but Jefferson
will do and you said to him mr.
Jefferson can you imagine look what
they've done they've replaced our gold
dollar with one consisting of
irredeemable paper and my guess is that
Jefferson would would look at the note
and look at you and say Gold dollar what
gold dollar because at the time nobody
imagined that the dollar would be
anything but a silver unit it was in
fact originally a unit based on the
Spanish silver dollar and and it was
intended that it should remain so with
the drafting of the Constitution and the
passage of the first coinage act of 1792
and in much subsequent legislation all
of the founders in all people at the
time took for granted that basic money
units or basic coins which is the same
thing back then would be silver units
because that's what they wear in the
rest of the world certainly the rest of
the Western world and so thinking of the
new currency unit of the United States
as a unit of silver was just following a
very widely established precedent in
fact until the latter half of the 19th
century the gold standard was
essentially an unknown thing the sole
exception perhaps having been that of
Great Britain which adopted a gold
standard officially more or less in 1816
but even then didn't
admit what with what it was doing if it
even realized it I'm reminded of
equipped that another economist once
made regarding a book by Hansen Holtz
who's a free-market economists whose
name should be familiar to many of you
he wrote a book called gold is money and
the remark made about it was that well
if you translated that book into that
book title into French you would have
loss of loss elegance and then if you
back translated it into English you'd
have gold is silver because the French
word for money
is silver it's the same thing and that's
because silver was money for such a long
time it was taken for granted that basic
money units would be silver units in
Britain itself by the way the pound
sterling was as its name ought to
suggests to you originally a silver unit
consisting of a troy pound of silver
that was a long time ago but it took the
British well into the 19th century to
shake the idea that their money that
their pound and related units were
anything other than silver units now the
u.s. switch ultimately to a gold
standard which would take place in
stages in the course of the 19th century
was also completely unintentional there
was nothing intentional about it it was
an accident
and an accident that quite a few people
came to regret the first coinage act
which I mentioned that of 1792 provided
of course for the minting or coining of
silver dollars but it also provided for
the free coining of gold Eagles which
were ten dollar pieces now there was a
very pro sake reason for that and it was
not so that we could have a bimetallic
standard though this is in fact what the
law ended up creating it was so that we
could have some coins for very large
transactions because if you think about
it right a a silver coin that is a
full-bodied silver coin worth ten times
as much as a silver dollar would have
been about as big as a pancake and
therefore rather clumsy to carry around
and so the idea was to have a ten dollar
pieces made of gold that wouldn't be so
clumsy but in those days remember nobody
thought that coins could pass for
anything other than their actual
metallic content and that perspective
plus the desire to avoid paper money
certainly on the part of Jefferson meant
that you had to have full-bodied coins
circulating according to the value of
the metal they contained which meant
gold and silver for convenience
particularly if you wanted foreign trade
to be handled as well as domestic
exchange and that meant bimetallism that
is a dollar that was unwittingly defined
not in terms of silver only but in terms
of two metals silver and gold a problem
well-known I'm sure to most of you with
bimetallism is that in practice if the
implicit valuation embodied in the gold
and silver coins of gold and silver that
is if if the implicit gold silver
exchange ratio differs from the ratio at
which those metals trade as commodities
in world markets then either the silver
will be officially undervalued or the
gold will be officially undervalued well
depending on which metal is undervalued
that one will not be brought for coining
to the mint and you will end up with the
other metal being the de-facto if not
the official standard metal for about
forty five years forty to forty five
years
the valuation official valuation of
silver and gold is embodied in the
silver dollars and the gold Eagles was
such that silver was the legally
overvalued coins
so there were not very many gold eagles
produced and we had in effect a silver
standard which was what the founders had
intended what they didn't intend of
course was that there wouldn't be many
Eagles produced which grazed problems
for large-scale transactions after the
gold finds of Appalachia particularly
this is around 1834 and also as a result
of a change in the official weight of
silver coins silver ended up being not
overvalued but undervalued and it was at
that time that silver stopped being
brought to the US Mint for coining and
gold instead was the only metal that it
was profitable to coin at that stage you
might say that we moved towards a gold
standard except in practice we didn't
for the simple reason that Eagles were
still the only gold coins and they were
absolutely useless for most transactions
so we ended up with silver coins that
were old and worn becoming our media of
exchange in other words we were still on
a silver standard you might call it a
worn out
silver standard and the worn-out silver
standard remained our standard even
though silver wasn't being freshly
coined for some years now ultimately the
gold rush in California sealed the fate
of the silver standard that and the fact
that the silver coins had become very
deteriorated but and gave more gave rise
to more aggressive gold coining but by
then the legislation had been changed so
that silver coins were being made not
dollars but smaller denomination coins
that were avowedly token coins that is
the silver in them was meant to be less
than the commodity value and those coins
of course could stay in circulation
and we're but they had to be minted on
the government's own accounts not freely
because nobody would use silver if
people had been able to make token coins
just by bringing their own silver to the
mint and they could have made quite a
bundle doing that so the government
produced small silver coins gold was
produced but still was only good for
large transactions and silver dollars
well they hadn't been seen for a long
time now the civil war meant the
suspension of gold and silver payments
of course in a temporary Fiat standard
that would stay into effect in effect
until 1879 during this the intervening
years many other countries found also as
a result of the falling world value of
gold that they too had inadvertently or
in some cases intentionally switched
from silver to gold standards many had
had bimetallic legislation themselves
and so Gresham's law encouraged their
switching also after the Civil War the
United States found itself joining these
other countries on in what became the
classical gold standard but again with
few exceptions nobody had intended that
this should be the result it was is it
where they're the outcome of a series of
accidents around the world one of the
important ones being of course those
california gold discoveries it wasn't
finally until the passage of the gold
standard act in 1900 that the united
states efficiently declared itself to be
not on a silver standard not honored by
metallic standard but simply on a gold
standard i want to add one more thing
the ultimate de-facto switched to an
official gold standard even before it
was acknowledged was highly
controversial as many of you know the
decision to stop producing silver
dollars which was if made official in
1873
and though such dollars had not been
minted for a long time was later
considered by many to have been a crime
nobody thought they were committing a
crime at the time they simply took the
silver dollar off the list of coins that
the mints would bake because they hadn't
been making them anyway for so long but
when after 1879 people realized that
silver had been effectively demonetised
and gold had been raised to the official
standard there was a great outcry by
persons particularly associated with the
agricultural parts of the country who
were faced with the deflation that they
associated with the gold standard in
which they felt a silver standard would
have avoided that's was of course the
basis for william jennings bryan famous
campaign he campaigned for the
revitalization of the silver standard he
ultimately lost that he gave a great
speech about the cross of gold in any
event we ended up on a gold standard
accidentally and the world ended up or
most of it ended up on a gold standard
and this international or classical gold
standard that prevailed in the last
decades of the 19th century and the
first decade or so of the 20th had a
number of wonderful features but the
features to a very large extent were not
specific to gold that is there was
nothing about it being an international
gold standard that made it work so well
it was the fact that it was an
international metallic standard that
really was key that was of course the
key to the fixed exchange rates this was
the only successful system of fixed
exchange rates ever known but they could
just as well have been a system of fixed
exchange rates among silver currencies
it just didn't work out that way
similarly the stable real purchasing
power of gold and that purchasing power
was remarkably stable over the period in
question could equally have been a
stable real purchasing power of
silver in fact milton freedman looking
at the real price of silver throughout
the period roughly from when britain
went on the gold standard in 1819 to the
end of the 19th century Friedman found
that the real purchasing power of silver
was actually a little bit more stable
than that of gold and he points out the
more countries that had remained on a
silver standard the more stable that
standard would have been so we could
very well be talking today if it hadn't
been for a number of accidents about the
wonderful silver standard that was even
more stable than the actual gold
standard that existed during that period
finally one more thing which should be
said about the classical gold standard
another reason why it worked so well
which also was not due to its being
based on gold rather than silver was the
fact that it wasn't managed by central
banks this is something that really
needs to be insisted on many of the
participating countries in the classical
gold standard including the United
States didn't have central banks Canada
another major participant had no central
bank and also had a very stable
financial system Switzerland didn't have
a central bank for most of the period in
question
Sweden didn't have one before 1901 and
it can be argued that the standard the
international classical gold standard
worked well because there were no
central banks around to muck it up when
the Bank of England which was of course
around did try to interfere with the
operation of the gold standard it
usually did so to try to controvert the
normal workings of that standard which
tended not to add to its stability but
to create short-run instability finally
I'd like to point out that the gold
standard the classical gold standard
didn't last very long if we can agree
that it really kicked in after the Civil
War it was over in 1914
some would argue that the gold standard
in this country only ended later in 1933
perhaps when Americans rut lost their
right to convert paper money into gold
or possibly in 1971 when foreigners that
is foreign central banks lost that
privilege but I would submit that the
gold standard as a self-sustaining
stable standard was finished with the
outbreak of World War one when of course
all the belligerent countries went off
the gold standard to some degree even
the United States in 1917 placed an
embargo on gold exports which could be
regarded as a partial suspension of the
gold standard after the war in the
course of the 1920s all countries tried
to restore the gold standard in some
fashion some after devaluing their
currencies that is making their paper
money's worth less than before in gold
others like Great Britain tried to
re-establish their old pen parities with
with ultimate lack of success it should
be said but the process the gold
standard that was recreated between the
wars is not was not a true gold standard
and more importantly was not a
sustainable gold standard it was a gold
standard that had the same quality as
the tape recorder in the beginning of
Mission Impossible episodes it was
programmed in this case unintentionally
to self-destruct not in five seconds but
in something like five years it was a
standard that was jury-rigged that
depended on most countries making their
holding as their reserves not gold
itself but sterling that is British
Pound credits at the Bank of England and
in some cases Federal Reserve credits
the system only worked if all the
countries agreed to keep those credits
and not cash them in the reason it had
to work that way was because there
wasn't enough gold around to sustain the
high price levels in
any supplies that still existed after
the war despite some deflation and
without further devaluations it was a
house of cards and when the French who
always spoil these things decided to
cash in their chips let it never be said
by the way that the English can have a
monopoly on sentiments about the French
particularly when it comes to
International Finance but in this case I
think in a way the French deserve some
credit
someone had to wreck that lousy system
it was bound to happen why not let the
French do it they're so good at wrecking
things if only they would wreck the euro
as effectively we would be in much
better shape so it all comes tumbling
down after 1930 and this is a big part
of the story of course of the Great
Depression a part week a story we cannot
go into in any detail after World War
two another attempt was made to cobble
together something that looked sort of
like the old gold standard it also had
the fixed exchange rate feature of the
old gold standard and yes gold was
behind it sort of this was the Bretton
Woods system but the Bretton Woods
system had all the bad features of the
interwar gold standard and then some
because unlike the international war
gold standard in the Bretton Woods
system it was understood upfront that
countries might devalue their currencies
under certain circumstances there wasn't
an apse an absolute commitment to gold
parities established after the war well
that of course just made the thing that
much more vulnerable to speculative
attacks and that much more likely to
destroy itself and inevitably to do so
eventually it didn't get working by the
way till 1958 and it was falling apart
by 1967 so nine years is the longest
life you can attribute to this system of
inherently unstable fixed exchange rates
based this time not on sterling but on
the US dollar other countries were
expected not to cash in their dollar
chips and
everything would be just fine it would
be especially fine of course for the
issuers of dollar chips or the issuer
the Federal Reserve System which
naturally issued plenty especially after
the Vietnam War guess who decided
eventually that they were tired of
holding these chips and that they would
destroy this international system the
French once again if they would stick to
destroying international monetary
systems instead of trying to create them
they wouldn't be so bad but they did
destroy this one after 67 and finally
the American authorities closed the gold
window in 71 after being unable despite
various attempts to district' gold
conversions and make them visible and
try to use diplomacy to force countries
not to cash in gold they finally gave up
in 71 though the gold standard
officially wasn't abandoned until 1976
so the gold standard was a very brief
episode the real gold standard and an
accidental one and silver could have
been just as good perhaps it would have
been better as an international standard
so does that mean we shouldn't be
talking in this session about returning
to gold should it be a session about
returning to silver or even to
bimetallism no I'm glad to say for the
sake of my colleagues because I'm sure
they're anxious to present their papers
Gold has become a focal point for
discussions of sound money for a good
reason we actually had an international
gold standard it actually worked very
well and you can't compare the
hypothetical of an international silver
standard to the reality of this well
working system surely
however challenging it might be to try
to get people to take the idea of
reestablishing a gold standard seriously
trying to get them to do so with regard
to a silver standard about which they
are they understand even less would be
too great a challenge to bother trying
to meet thank you very much
well thank you George our next speaker
dr. Brian dmitriyevich holds a PhD in
history from Harvard University which we
won't hold against him where Elsa did
graduate work in the Economics
Department
his a/b is from Columbia University
where he studied history and mathematics
he's chairman of the Department of
History at Sam Houston State University
which is down the road and he lives in
Woodlands suburb of of Houston he's also
the author of the standard history of
supply-side economics called Chicano
class the rebels who sparked the
supply-side revolution and restarted
American prosperity for some reason I'm
up here with authors who have very long
titles for their books but that's from I
aside books from 2009 it's a very good
one as well he has written for The Wall
Street Journal investors business daily
Forbes and other outlets and he's
appeared many times on television and
radio from the Kudlow report to Lou
Dobbs tonight to PR i--'s the world and
for the past few years he has have been
a weekly columnist on forbes.com where
you can read them under the byline past
and present pretties welcome dr. at
dmitrieva
[Applause]
thanks a lot Gary it's great to be part
of this Hillsdale van Hill sale such an
essential institution in this great
nation of ours
I'm historian not an economist so they
trained a little bit in economics and I
just want to talk a little bit about our
history a recent history the history
that we know so well are the own history
are the economic history of our lives as
a reason that we should advocate the
gold standard as a reason that we should
realize we have to go back to the gold
standard pretty quickly in a remarkable
book published in 2009 money markets and
sovereignty been style and Manuel Hines
make the keen observation that over the
millennia of human history since ancient
times there have been very few long runs
in which the whole world has been on a
Fiat money standard in fact they point
out the most notable period is our own
the last 41 years which George has
mentioned since 1971 when the United
States ended its guarantee to foreign
monetary authorities that dollars could
be exchanged with the Treasury for gold
for $35 an ounce any arguments about
returning to a commodity money standard
particularly a gold standard should take
into account these times these last 41
years after all they are our own times
what lesson has the contemporary age
given about the advisability of a gold
standard the pattern of the last four
decades has been a most interesting one
there had been three defined periods in
our nation's economic history since 1971
since Nixon went off gold and it is
striking how distinctively instructive
these periods are about the choice
between fiat money and the gold standard
since 1971
we have experienced stagflation the
dozen year run from the 70s into the
early 80s when prices tripled
unemployment kept stepping up from 4%
all the way to 11%
we had three double-dip recession xand
stocks lost two-thirds of their real
value that was stagflation then
beginning in 1982 and lasting all the
way through 2007 though the meat of it
was the 80s and the 90s we had what has
come to be known as the Great Moderation
the Great Moderation where growth came
in quite well the whole while 3.3
percent per year there were only two
recessions in the whole 25 year run both
of the mild inflation crashed to 2/3 the
average of the stagflation period
unemployment got back to structural
levels and stocks went on one of their
greatest tears of all time and then the
third period since 1971 as we are all
too aware after the Great Moderation
came the Great Recession we know it's
odious characteristics all too well
growth skidded into a major trough and
then clocked the lowest rates of any
recovery since the Great Depression
unemployment and underemployment had let
hit levels also unseen since the 1930s
affecting over 20 million individuals
stocks and other investments have lost
money often big money so there's the
sequence since 1971 since the last
vestige of the gold standard when
sayonara
stagflation for a dozen years the Great
Moderation for 25 and the Great
Recession for 5 now if you want to take
it back one more period to the years
before 1971 you have of course post-war
prosperity the most famous and beloved
run of economic performance in American
memory post-war prosperity was that two
and a half decades span after World War
two when growth came in very nicely
actually at the same rate as the Great
Moderation 3.3 percent per year jobs and
opportunity were a plenty inflation and
unemployment were pretty close to being
non problems and investments did very
well indeed so what we have for the
sweep of contemporary economic history
is this is a cycle over 60 some years
post-war prosperity stagflation Great
Moderation
Great Recession now there's a secret to
all this there is a control across all
of this history it is the price of gold
the price of gold when gold was low and
stable in price we got the great runs
post-war prosperity and the Great
Moderation
when gold was manic in price and
shooting upward
we got the extended busts stagflation
and now the Great Recession
it's true throughout post-war prosperity
gold traded at $35 an ounce now to be
sure there were deficiencies in the gold
market in those days which we can talk
about if you like we've already talked
about a little bit but the basic point
is that the US ultimately had to
guarantee the dollar as 135th an ounce
of gold to very major international
players namely foreign monetary
authorities gold was low and stable in
price from 1945 to 1971 $35 an ounce and
we got post-war prosperity again no less
than the most cherished run of extended
opportunity in Clover in American memory
then a big change came after 1971 Gold
lost all its stability and gained
altitude like never before
immediately after the u.s. went off gold
in that year it went up in international
markets in a most major way and when in
1974 the United States once again
allowed a domestic gold market the gold
price was five times higher than it had
been before one hundred and seventy five
dollars per ounce over the next six
years in the 1970s gold went all the way
up to $800 an ounce a level hit in 1980
making for a fully twenty three-fold
increase in the price of gold in just
one stagflation decade people have read
my book accounting class you know that
begins with a story about the movie
Goldfinger which was made in 1964 the
James Bond movie and the the criminal in
the James Bond movie Goldfinger is
trying to blow up Fort Knox so that it
will increase the price of his own gold
and he says I hope it increases by 10
times after this big criminal enterprise
well well you just wait for the
stagflation decade it'll go up 23 times
and then no nuclear explosions needed
the outlines of a program a pattern
emerged by 1980 low and stable gold
post-war prosperity manic and skyward
gold stagflation then after 1982 with
the Great Moderation which again on all
the notable real economic metrics was a
repeat of the good record of post-war
prosperity here's what happened to gold
right away and basically for the
duration Gold tumbled to a low level in
price and stayed there in the early
1980s just as the Ronald Reagan
Revolution was getting
implemented in policy gold fell from
those $800 heights to a tight range
around the $350 mark and $350 to ever
take about 20% but basically the $350
gold stayed there for two decades 1982
to 2002 loser these were truly the great
years of the Great Moderation the Ronald
Reagan 1980s in the Newt Gingrich 1990s
when growth was just about always over
4% per year the Great Moderation started
to lose power in the George W Bush years
when growth struggled to get to 3%
instead of the easy 4% marks always hit
in the previous two decades and what you
might expect to happen indeed happened
gold shed it's low and stable nature
going from that 350 dollar point of
orientation in 2002 which had held for
two decades all the way up to $800 again
by 2007 then came the Great Recession
and gold Dooley motored right up to
$1,700 an ounce thus did the outline of
the pattern that emerged after post-war
prosperity and stagflation hardened into
something definitive with low and stable
gold there comes a multi-decade boom in
the economy a boom that will be fabled
and beloved by public that cherishes the
American Dream with manic and
skyrocketing gold there comes an
extended economic underperformance
detested by a public that cherishes the
American dream simple correlation or
actual causation this tie between low
and stable gold and the great runs of
prosperity and the rush into gold with
horrid exceptions to prosperity you can
work out the economics of it and they
are not particularly esoteric and my
colleagues here are offering clear
information in this direction but the
simple correlation is simply too strong
to be indifferent to or complacent about
this correlation is that the prosperity
that is characteristic of this great
nation comes when gold is low and stable
and price and nasty interruptions in the
progress of the American dream occur
when gold becomes a favored investment
in rockets up in price thus the argument
for returning to the gold standard is at
bottom a real one in the economic sense
if we want the likes of extended
prosperity say like what we had during
post-war prosperity or the Great
Moderation or even better we need low
and stable gold if we are indifferent to
extended prosperity we can like Federal
Reserve Chairman Ben Bernanke being
different to a skyrocketing price of
gold there does not appear to be an
option historically by the lights of
contemporary history of being
indifferent toward gold being low and
stable and being serious about American
prosperity the to simply historically as
a matter of fact go together low stable
gold Greg run of prosperity the basic
reason for the correlation is tipped off
by the government's posture towards the
economy across the post-war prosperity
stagflation Great Moderation Great
Recession sequence during the Anker
periods of post-war prosperity and the
Great Moderation
the federal government of the United
States took clear steps at limiting the
fiscal and monetary power of this
country to the benefit of the real which
is to say the ex governmental sector of
the economy the Anker years of post-war
prosperity were those surrounding the
big John F Kennedy tax cuts of the
mid-1960s a fiscal action which
coincided with a major defense of the
dollar on the part of the Fed which took
the form of the tripling of the federal
funds rate from historical lows in the
early 60s monetary policy that aimed at
dollar strength and stability
coupled with fiscal policy that sought a
retreat of the federal footprints and
let it be remembered that federal
spending declined from 1964 to 1965 just
prior to the Great Society this was the
policy mix at the center of the
incredible 5% per year run and growth
from 1961 to 1969 without which there
would have been no post-war prosperity
likewise the Great Moderation in 1982
the Fed was busy busying itself with
reestablishing the value of the dollar
against consumer prices after the recent
experience of 200 percent cumulative
inflation and from the executive Ronald
Reagan came big tax cuts and efforts of
deregulation dollars soundness and a
retreat of the fiscal sector thus came
the boom that was the Great Moderation
in both episodes what of course happen
with respect to gold was that nobody
wanted to be in this asset class anymore
that functions best as an alternative to
investment in the real sector when
opportunities are great in the real
sector when the prospect of profits
opportunities and newness are bountiful
people get out of gold which pays no
interest and has carrying costs and into
investments in the actual economy that
translate into things like jobs products
earnings and bounty and since this basic
posture of federal retreat from fiscal
expansion and currency manipulation
largely maintained itself through the
1980s and 1990s gold stayed low the
whole while during the first two-thirds
of the Great Moderation
low and stable gold necessarily comes if
the real sector is primed to roar and
stay that way now alternatively speaking
of the other periods stagflation got
inaugurated back in 1969 on the heels of
a tax increase in a Federal Reserve bent
on stimulating the economy through money
printing and debt purchase the immediate
effect was a busting of the $35 gold
price hence the 71 decision to go off
gold but the basic structural
development is the important thing after
1969 the United States committed itself
to monetary manipulation fiscal
expansion in the form of statutory and
non-statutory tax increases along with
expansions in spending that made federal
expenditures in the post-vietnam era
even higher than they had been prior of
course gold went way up in this era
government was displacing the real
sector who was fooling with the medium
of exchange same thing with our Great
Recession and it's run up the George W
Bush tax cuts of the early two-thousands
such as they were were exceeded in size
and scope by the spending increases and
the Fed kept interest rates at
exceedingly low levels for so long that
they stoked the housing bubble new
spending Trump's trump tax cuts on the
fiscal side and monetary manipulation
once again became the order of the day
this amounted to an expansion of the
fiscal sector at the expense of the real
so we got the 2008 bust as the investors
as investors fled the real Akana
me gold is simply the most obvious haven
of retreat when it comes when it becomes
clear that the government is diminishing
the scope of the ex government economy
the lesson of all this contemporary
history would appear to be quite clear
above all formerly stabilised the price
of gold at a nice low level that should
be the imperative of policy because if
you have low price of gold its stable it
only coincides in real life with these
incredible runs now of course this is
not to be done through gimmicks
governmental manipulation of the gold
markets and boy was this tried in the
1960s such that the price stays low and
stable has nothing to recommend it the
point is to make it the case that the
private market for gold freely stays low
and stable well how do you do that it's
actually elementary as post-war
prosperity in the Great Moderation show
it would have been a piece of cake for
the United States to fix the price of
gold at thirty five dollars or three
hundred and fifty dollars for all buyers
foreign and domestic in these years
after all the price of gold was in fact
stable in these times if the United
States had guaranteed the dollar at the
market price in these past cases the
action would have had no effect the u.s.
is buying and selling gold a three
hundred fifty dollars an ounce during
the 1980s and 1990s well so what that's
the market price anyway the only
conceivable effect would have been to
convince further agents in the economy
that the United States was serious about
letting the real economy run forever
after all if the United States after
putting the dollar formally on gold
would then go for tax increases
regulations new spending plans money
printing and the like all of it would
lead to a big increase in the private
gold price and thus a run on the u.s.
gold stock at the low fixed press so the
US wouldn't do that and post-war
prosperity or the Great Moderation would
continue and continue and continue no
speculation no Great Recession no such
beasts associated with governments on
the march and huge private postage
pushes into gold and out of real
investments it remains a great tragedy
it would have been a piece of cake for
the United States to guarantee the
dollar 350
to anyone in the 80s and 90s and we'd
have never had the last decade of the
2000s and today would still be clock
that's 4.5% growth rates greatest missed
opportunity of contemporary economic
history the argument for returning to
gold can draw deeply from all of this
nation's history the incredible growth
century that was the latter half of the
19th century shows this abundantly but
our own history is that which is closest
to us in the one that ultimately must
give us confidence about what reforms
are the ones to be made the history of
our own age and of the previous two
generations those since World War two
provides an impossibly clear lesson that
the great reform that has gone unmade
this whole while is getting the dollar
got back on a gold standard since a gold
standard formalizes gold is low unstable
in price the necessary condition maybe
it's the sufficient condition of
extended runs of prosperity comes into
place what better reason could there
possibly be for a gold standard it
guarantees the likes of the best booms
of the very American century and there
should be no confusion that low and
stable gold is a necessary condition to
such prosperity the kind that makes the
American dream a reality the sequence of
post-war prosperity stagflation the
Great Moderation the Great Recession
only confirms this point with resounding
clarity and consistency yet there is one
problem and it is particularly relevant
in our own time that of the extended
Great Recession this is that it is far
easier to get the dollar back on gold
when gold is already low and stable in
price privately again to have gone on
gold in the 80s or 90s would have been a
piece of cake since a good low get
stable price was prevailing anyway
privately what a tremendous missed
opportunity that this formal action was
never taken not going on gold when it
was so very possible a decade and a half
ago represents the tragedy of the long
boom inaugurated by the Reagan reforms
the action should be taken that should
be taken now then is for a repeat of the
policy mix of the JFK and the Ronald
Reagan years that committed the
government to a posture of retreat with
respect to the real sector a nice spate
of tax cuts deregulation and spending
cuts would suck money out of gold
into real investment and get us out of
this print Isis sluggishness clearly the
price of gold would fall under such a
regime of reform I believe is something
like $600 an ounce and stay there for a
little while as the governmental retreat
was committed to right there when that
happens the United States must formalize
the dollars convertibility to gold then
the Fed would be stuck with created
creating only as many dollars as the
real economy required any more would be
committed to hedges like gold and US
bust the standard moreover the
government would be committed to keeping
taxes spending regulation and the like
modest so that confidence in the real
sector could be maintained preventing
flight into gold and out of investments
the great lesson of contemporary
economic history is that to date we have
failed to perceive that all along this
history is an amount has amounted to an
argument for the gold standard if we
want to return to the heights of the
post-war era or our dear departed 1980s
and 1990s in fact if we want to do even
a little better we must get the dollar
formally on gold indifference to the
gold price is the alternative and that
has only given us conditions inimical to
the American dream stagflation in the
Great Recession we must return to gold
because as the proven correlate to the
kind of blooming prosperity we Americans
cherish in which so many generations yet
possibly excluding the newest have known
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
well another great presentation we're
going to be followed with a third-grade
presentation by Larry White he is the
press of economics at George Mason
University we were just talking that we
currently have seven hills of college
graduates in the ph.d program in
economics at George Mason because they
have such fine teachers as as Larry he
specializes in the theory and history of
banking and money and is best known for
his work on free banking he received his
a B from Harvard and his MA and PhD from
the University of California at Los
Angeles he's previously taught at New
York University the University of
Georgia and the University of Missouri
at st. Louis he is the author of four
books and his most recent one was just
published this year and I've heard that
it's really climbing in the in Amazon
entitled the clash of economic ideas the
great policy debates and experiments of
the last hundred years his articles on
monetary theory and banking history have
appeared in the American Economic Review
the Journal of economic literature the
journal of money credit and banking and
other leading professional journals
he's the co-editor of econ journal watch
and host bimonthly podcasts for ejw
audio he also blogs at free banking orgs
so join me in welcoming Larry white
thank you Gary
and thanks to Hillsdale and the Darrell
foundation it's a pleasure to be here
okay my slides are up so some of you may
have noticed that during the Republican
primary season some vaguely favorable
sentiments about the gold standard were
expressed by a few of the candidates and
some of you may have noticed that in the
republican party platform there's a call
for a new gold commission
well they don't use the word gold a new
commission to consider putting the
dollar on a metallic basis now that kind
of sentiment those kinds of expressions
have of course brought forth critics of
the gold standard so I'm here to talk
about some of the arguments they've
offered in recent years now that the
challenge before me is not that these
arguments are really hard to refute the
challenge before me is that they're so
easy to refute that you'll think I'm
just studying up straw men so in the
paper I actually will quote these
arguments at length to try to convince
you that they're setting up the straw
man I'm just knocking it down but I
think it's a useful service because some
of these arguments sound plausible if
you don't know anything about monetary
theory or anything about economic
history now some of the authors of these
arguments do know better and so it's
actually kind of shocking in some cases
how flimsy the arguments are I'm going
to focus on two economists in particular
one the UC Berkeley economist Barry
Eichengreen who last year published a
piece in the national interest called a
critique of pure gold and the other is
an obscure former Princeton professor
named Benjamin Bernanke who used to be
on the Council of Economic Advisers so
maybe you heard of him then he gave a
guest lecture at George Washington
University recently and in the New York
Times account of this lecture he
framed much of this history as a
critique of the gold standard which was
dropped in the early 1930s in a decision
that mainstream economists regard is
obviously correct hugely beneficial and
essentially irreversible but the
criticism of the gold standard is
bipartisan well Bernanke was appointed
by a Republican president I'm also gonna
mention James Hamilton from University
of California San Diego who is a
monetarist and Bruce Bartlett the
one-time supply-side economist for some
reason joining the pylon so the the
first argument I want to consider is
probably the simplest there isn't enough
gold to operate a gold standard today
and I attribute this one to a columnist
for USA Today but there are other
examples and there is a very facile
answer which i think is not correct the
fashionable answer is well we just
raised the price of gold excuse me hmm
as far as necessary to make the value of
our gold stock equal to the value of our
money supply well what would that take
that would take something like eight
thousand dollars an ounce and you can't
really do that when the world price of
gold is sixteen hundred dollars an ounce
because the United States would be
flooded with gold which would be used to
buy assets and goods and services and we
would end up selling an awful lot of
stuff to the rest of the world in
exchange for gold that's oh that's a
very expensive piece of advice the
reason we don't need to do that
fortunately is that the money supply can
be a multiple of the stock of gold and
I'm going to argue it is when you don't
intervene to stop that and and this the
USA Today columnist seems to have
misunderstood each dollar of money can
be spent more than once a year
all right so you can't just compare
fifteen trillion dollars of economy to
however many billion dollars of gold
there are and say that's not enough
right
money can be spent more than once a year
right
I'm assuming that a gold standard does
not mean a monetary system in which
people just use gold coins and nothing
else
I believe in modern banking well not not
what we have today not postmodern
banking in which there are no standards
but sound banking interesting footnote
that comes from the book that Gary
mentioned that like all authors I need
to mention repeatedly so you don't
forget the title the clash of economic
ideas many of you may have heard the
famous phrase attributed to Keynes that
gold is a barbarous relic the phrase he
actually seems to have cribbed from a
classical neoclassical economist named
Edwin cannon and cannon referred to that
relic of barbarism countries that only
want to use gold coins and want to
suppress the use of banknotes and
checking accounts which gives it a very
different spin right you can have a gold
standard without limiting the economy to
physical gold coins so a gold standard
the way I'm going to use it means gold
is the medium of account
it's what things are priced in and gold
is the medium of redemption it's the
stuff that's in bank vaults that you can
redeem your bank issued money for if you
want to but in a properly functioning
banking system you very seldom will want
to okay so is there enough gold well
here's my back of the envelope
calculation and I'm assuming that we're
gonna take the price of gold as it is
today around $1700 an ounce the US
government has 261 million ounces of
gold if you value that at $1,700 an
ounce it gives you four hundred and
forty four point six billion dollars
that's about four times a little more
than four times current required bank
reserves so it's more than enough to
supply banks with all the reserves they
are legally required to hold against
there
it accounts if you think of it another
way if you ask how big a reserve ratio
would it give banks against the monetary
aggregate m1 which is the sum of
currency and circulation and checking
account dollars it gives you about 19
percent against m1 and by historical
standards that's plenty it's it's true
it's less than the official reserve
ratio that was fastened on the Federal
Reserve System in the days of the gold
standard to try to the interwar gold
standard not a real gold standard to try
to pin the Federal Reserve down but when
money was issued by commercial banks
this was a very healthy more than
necessary reserve ratio so there's
plenty of gold at least in the United
States we'd have to sort of go around
the world to see where the rest of it's
gone here's an argument that Eichengreen
makes to use gold as money and quoting
him is to fix its price in domestic
currency terms and Eichengreen
says this is very puzzling that free
market advocates would want to fix a
price right don't they believe in freely
fluctuating prices set by the market
well look the the official price of gold
is not really a price right 20 dollars
and 67 cents an ounce was not a price
it was the inverse of the gold
definition of the dollar which was 1
over 20 point 67 of an ounce of gold so
it's not something that goes up and down
with supply and demand it's conventional
or legislated or established by
definition in the case of the the
Spanish milled dollar the US Congress
initially adopted what was the given
content of that dollar in terms of how
many grains of silver it was so putting
it into law didn't make something new up
it just codified what already existed
but once you've defined the dollar as a
weight of gold you don't have a
fluctuating price between dollars in
gold they're the same good
what does fluctuate in response to
changes in supply and demand is the
purchasing power of gold or if you like
the relative price of gold in terms of
goods and services and that does move in
response to supply and demand but it
tends to settle back down to where it
started because if there's an increase
in demand for gold that raises the value
of gold gold miners will start producing
more and they'll have an incentive to
produce more than usual as long as the
purchasing power is higher than usual
but that in itself will drive it back
down and likewise on the other side I
actually used this quote from
Eichengreen on an exam I gave last week
to my students where the exercises spot
the fallacy right so here's how silly it
is to talk about this as an example of
price fixing I couldn't get a picture of
Eichengreen going to his bank but I got
a picture of this gentleman withdrawing
money at his bank I doubt I can Green
regards it as a case of price fixing
that every time he goes to the ATM in
exchange for giving up one dollar of his
checking account he gets one Federal
Reserve Note dollar that's not a fixed
price right that's the one-for-one
definition of what a dollar in a
checking account means according to the
contractual terms with his bank so
that's not a price fixing ratios and
likewise if you go to the bank and get
one twentieth of an ounce of gold for
turning in a dollar or whatever the
ratio would be today that's not price
fixing that's the definition of the
monetary unit in terms of gold while I
was looking for an ATM picture I found
this one this is in the airport in Dubai
where you have an ATM that spits out
little biscuits of gold so a modern
technology is keeping up the gold
standard is not an old-fashioned system
third argument I want to consider people
look at the volatility of the price of
gold in recent years and say well you'd
be insane to hit your money to gold
because gold is all over the map as
Brian was telling us it's shot up to
$1,700 an ounce and Eichengreen and
others talk about the inherent
volatility in the price of gold and Jim
Hamilton who I mentioned has a
calculation as to how much nominal wages
would have had to fall to keep them the
same in real terms if they had been
fixed in gold right because as the value
of gold goes up you have to get fewer
gold dollars but it's a crazy
calculation because the reason the price
of gold has gone up to $1700 is that
people are buying gold as an inflation
hedge I think that's pretty obvious and
so that's a problem or it's a symptom of
a problem it's a symptom of the
unreliability of fiat money but it's a
problem experienced under fiat standards
it's not a problem experienced under a
gold standard under a gold standard you
don't buy gold to speculate against
inflation right Gold is the monetary
standard and you look at his historical
experience there's basically no
inflation certainly over the medium to
long term there's no inflation Hamilton
has a different view he wants to claim
that the reason the price of gold is
shooting up is because of a surge in
income in emerging economies and he
cites one years worth of data in which
the purchase of jewelry in India gold
jewelry in India shot up but if you look
over a longer period of time and more
countries you see that the volatility in
the price of gold is driven mostly by
investment demand what they call
investment demand which is people buying
coins bullion and exchange-traded funds
in gold even jewelry purchases in India
are partly an inflation hedge right
people buy gold because they figure the
price is going up they figure the
purchasing power the rupee is only going
down I think I can confirm this yes so
what we need to ask is under which
system do you have greater volatility
under which system do you have less
volatility
so here's someone buying a gold biscuit
and the simple fact the historical fact
is that money supply and demand shocks
have been worse under fiat money systems
right this is not a necessary truth but
it is an empirical truth under the
classical gold system there were some
supply shocks you've heard about the
California Gold Rush but you may be
surprised to learn how small these
shocks were in terms of the impact they
had on the purchasing power of gold so
the California Gold Rush followed just a
couple years later by the Australian
Gold Rush was the largest supply shock
under the gold standard huge outpouring
of gold it cumulatively raised the world
price level by 26% but that was over a
stretch of 18 years from 1849 to 1867
and that's the point at which the world
price level stopped rising if you work
that out that's an inflation rate of 1.3
percent per annum right and that's the
worst case the average over the entire
period in which Great Britain was on the
gold standard was 0.1% inflation it's so
very very close to zero in fact if you
choose different starting and ending
points you can get a little bit positive
or a little bit negative so very close
to zero on the demand side you don't
have big shocks to the demand for gold
when gold is money
because there's no reason for people to
want to hoard money as an inflation
hedge well right that's self-defeating
or to think that the price of gold is
about to jump upward and therefore want
to hoard it what we do have this problem
today under fiat money and I said an
article by Robert barro who identified
this in the 80s where he said look since
we D linked from gold we see a lot more
volatility in the inflation rate and
that's because when people see inflation
coming they now want to hold less money
and move into real assets so in in terms
of monetary Theory the velocity of money
goes up and that drives the price level
up
so kind of one-time adjustment as people
are shrinking their money holdings but
when you have volatile inflation
expectations as you do under a current
regime you get volatile behavior in the
demand to hold money under the gold
standard you did not have volatile
inflation expectations inflation was
anchored people's inflation expectations
were anchored so you didn't see these
kind of demand shocks which are the
creature of a Fiat money regime and not
of a gold standard regime well some
economists have noticed that the gold
standard didn't in fact produce secular
inflation and they want to use that
against it
so they say well it would be a source of
harmful deflation I mentioned Bruce
Bartlett earlier Bartlett argued in a
recent piece that the long-run inflation
rate under the gold standard was close
to zero only because periods of
inflation were followed by periods of
what he called debilitating deflations
my colleague at George Mason Tyler Cowen
has made the same argument that the
problem with the gold standard is that
sometimes the purchasing power is going
to go up and that means deflation and to
quote him thereby harming output and
employment but the thereby is just a non
sequitur we have to distinguish between
harmful inflation's there is a kind of
harmful inflation and benign inflated
sorry deflation between harmful
deflations and benign deflation or good
deflations and george Celgene book less
than zero the case for falling prices in
a growing economy is that right freely
available on the web so I'm not giving
any George George any additional income
by mentioning this but maybe some
additional citations I recommend very
highly as making this distinction but
other economists have belatedly started
to recognize it there was a piece even
in the American Economic Review by
Attkisson and Kehoe which they go
through all the historical cases they
could find of deflations defined as
falling prices over a five-year span and
then they asked the very simple question
was output also
falling over that five-year span so was
there a depression over the same span
that there was a deflation they count 73
episodes of deflation so this is looking
at many countries over many years only
an 8 out of 73 cases was their shrinking
output so there's no overall Association
by the way there was shrinking output in
some cases where there was inflation
there's no overall connection between
falling prices and falling output and it
should be obvious that if you keep the
money supply constant or growing very
slowly you're going to have falling
prices when the output of goods is
growing rapidly right you have the same
number of dollars chasing more goods or
more Goods chasing the same number of
dollars you're going to have Goods
selling at lower prices but you can't
regret that it can't be harmful to have
deflation driven by rapid output growth
rapid output growth is exactly what you
want in the paper I look at the period
the longest period of deflation under
the US gold standard which is 1882 to
1897 so it's 15 years prices fell at a
compound rate annual rate of 1.7% a year
all right so that's nearly two percent
that sounds like it could be pretty
damaging to the economy but if you look
at real output in the economy that was
growing at three percent a year over the
same period right so it was hardly
restraining economic growth that was
about the average of the 19th century
and this is the sort of thing right
where this a Tandy computer used to be
$5,000 it did have two floppy drives
after all so that justified the high
price tag but deflation driven by
productivity is a case where particular
Goods get cheaper to produce their price
Falls why should we regret that to say
we should regret the price index falling
is to say when we have cases like this
we should offset them by making sure
other
as all go up a little bit right that
doesn't make any sense there's no
problem created by a good becoming
cheaper to produce and therefore
producers bringing it to market and
selling it at a lower price the reason
of course deflation has a bad reputation
is the Great Depression so I needed to
talk now about the Great Depression but
the Great Depression was not a case in
which prices were falling because the
economy was flooded with output it was
because the money supply was shrinking
so rapidly that's a very different story
in that case you do get unsold
inventories of goods if prices are and
wage rates are sticky coming down but
that's a different thing from the
typical deflation under the classical
gold standard
now some people worried have worried in
recent years that clearly the Federal
Reserve's actions during the financial
crisis saved our bacon kept us from
plunging into the abyss therefore we
want to have a central bank that's able
to do whatever is necessary therefore we
don't want a gold standard because that
ties the government's hands alright
that's the argument well here's Ben
Bernanke at George Washington University
he says a gold standard means that no
matter how high the unemployment rate
goes you've promised not to try to do
anything about it
well that's right but I don't regard
that as a shortcoming I regard that as a
virtue and there's a well-known argument
according to which it's a virtue here's
the classical version of it right where
you get better outcomes by restricting
your own discretion
this is Ulysses tied to the mast so that
he can hear the song of the sirens
without being tempted to steer the boat
over onto the rocky shoals and smash the
boat up there's a similar problem in
monetary policy which is sirens are
singing in Ben Bernanke's ear saying the
unemployment rates too high you have to
bring it down and in doing so he's
tempted to print more money than is
consistent with keeping the value of the
dollar stable all right we want his
hands tied against that sort of thing
because
unemployment is not a monetary problem I
mean it can be a side effect of not
having enough money but if he just makes
sure that we have enough and not too
much money and if he takes care of
monetary equilibrium the labor market is
another thing that can take care of
itself and trying to cure labor market
problems by printing money gets you into
a race between the printing press and
the labor unions you don't want to go
there we've been there alright not a
pretty story so let's get to the the
argument that the gold standard
amplifies business cycles this is meant
to be a picture of a bank run I realized
after I put it on the slide that it kind
of looks like people looting the bank
but it's meant to be a bank run and the
worry of some economists and I quote
Tyler Cowen again in the paper is what
they call the pro cyclic allottee of the
money supply that is when times are bad
people will pull their money out of the
bank that'll make the money supply
shrink that'll make the economy even
worse right so it'll amplify the
business cycle in that way but it's not
true that a gold standard makes the
money supply more procyclical because
it's not true that it leads to bank runs
or credit crunches now in the u.s. there
happens to be a coincidence in US
history between the period of the
classical gold standard the late 19th
century up to the founding of the
Federal Reserve and weak banking system
and financial panics but the u.s. is not
the only country in the world if we just
look north of the border in Canada
during the same period also on a gold
standard there are no financial panics
right there's some spillover from the US
panics but there are no Canadian panics
people are bringing their money into the
bank while the u.s. is having bank runs
so it can't be the gold standard that's
responsible it's got to be something
different between the two countries and
the different thing is Canada had a
rational banking system because they
didn't restrict the banks in ways that
made them weak they didn't restrict
branch banking the way we did the United
States and they didn't put a limit on
the amount of bank notes banks could
issue
depending on how much government debt
they owned we did that in the u.s.
because it was a way of financing the
Union government during the Civil War
right but it meant the bank's couldn't
provide more currency in seasons where
there was a peak demand for currency and
all the financial panics began in the
autumn because that's that was the peak
season for demanding currency banks that
couldn't issue their own currency had to
give up reserves and now there's a
problem there's not enough reserves to
go around so let's talk about the Great
Depression
there's a famous thesis called golden
fetters which is associated with Barry
Eichengreen 1992 book by that title then
the phrase golden fetters comes from
Keynes so that gives you a hint as to
where I can Green is coming from but
there are kind of two parts to the
thesis first part is that the gold
standard and I quote Doug Irwin from
Dartmouth as to what the thesis is the
gold standard was the key factor in the
origins of the Great Depression so
that's part one and part two is a key
factor in the transmission of the Great
Depression from country to country so
let me first deal with the deflation
question in the United States this is a
picture of the paper currency that was
issued in Great Britain it's actually a
10 shilling note which is a pretty small
denomination during the First World War
and the real problem of the deflation
well to understand the deflation in the
30s we have to go we have to talk about
the interwar period as a whole you've
already heard a little about it and how
it wasn't really a true gold standard it
was a jerry-rigged gold exchange system
and to understand the interwar period we
have to go back to World War one and I
put most of the blame for the interwar
deflation on the first world wars
monetary experience which was inflation
of course countries went off the gold
standard in order to print money in
order to pay their war bills the great
economist Leland Yeager was once to
asked would you recommend going back on
a gold standard
and he said yes I would but I would also
recommend that well while we're doing it
we repeal the First World War and that's
kind of my position too but what
happened in the First World War was as I
said the government's issued a lot of
money in the in Great Britain the price
level basically doubled so at the end of
the war you've got a pound which buys
half as much as the amount of gold that
the pound used to be equivalent to still
buys all right so how do you bring those
two things back into alignment you have
a choice you either cut the gold content
of the pound or if you want to keep the
gold content of the pound you're gonna
have to bring the price level back down
which means you have to go through a
major major deflation and unless you can
adjust prices and wages flexibly that's
going to be a problem and of course
Keynes was famous for warning that this
was a bad idea to go back to gold at the
old parity but he wasn't the only one to
warn this Mises warned against the same
thing Mises said look the damage done by
the inflation has been done you don't
reverse it by now having a massive
deflation and I like his analogy he says
once you've run over a man with a truck
you don't do him a favor by putting the
truck in reverse and backing over him
right so the sensible thing to do even
though you would like to have a system
that retains the same parity once you've
had a world war you can say okay in that
case once we've doubled the price level
now the sensible thing to do is devalue
cut the value of the pound in half the
gold value of the pound in half and then
we can sustain that value but instead
they tried to go back to the old parity
without enough gold to do it with a
price level so high that if you could
get gold you would take it right because
gold had a bigger purchasing power in
the world market than the number of
pounds it took you to get the ounce of
gold those pounds only bought half as
much so gold was massively hemorrhaging
from Great Britain and they couldn't
sustain it
so countries that did that we're gonna
have a deflation in the US we had a big
deflation in nineteen twenty and
twenty-one but it didn't entirely
reverse the inflation the US had during
the war but countries in Europe had even
more more inflation than the US did so
they were way above the gold parity and
they had to make this choice and so many
countries went back to the original
standard that there was going to have to
be a deflation okay the gold standard
spreading to the rest of the world I
think there's a grain of truth in that
but there's a little more to the story
that needs to be mentioned which is the
United States and the Bank of France
France again as George mentioned we're
ruining things by stockpiling gold they
weren't playing according to the normal
rules they were gathering up so much
gold and just putting it in vaults and
not letting it affect the money supply
that other countries were losing gold
and I think there is an important lesson
here and the important lesson is you
don't want to go back onto a gold
standard with central banks you want a
gold standard where the right to issue
money is more decentralized than that
you don't want to have an institution
which has the power to over issue money
and then has the power to suspend
payments in a system of decentralized no
tissue a free banking system any one
bank can devalue or sorry can't devalue
and one bank can go broke but it doesn't
make the monetary system change it
doesn't devalue the currency it affects
that Bank it doesn't affect the entire
system so nobody is in a position to
devalue and because no bank is going to
be relieved from the mistakes it made
banks are going to behave more prudently
and that's the answer to the last one I
have time to cover which is that a gold
standard system would be subject to
speculative attacks like George Soros
launched against the pound in 1991 and
like took place in the United States in
1933
when it was suspected that Roosevelt was
gonna devalue if nobody can devalue then
there's no reason for a speculative
attack there's no profit to be made by
borrowing money waiting for the
devaluation and then repaying the loan
by buying back the currency you borrowed
at a lower price so I'll have to end
there thanks very much
[Applause]
well thank you very much we have a time
for a few couple of questions anyway one
thing again wait for the speaker to wait
for the microphone to get to you please
try to make it a question rather than a
statement and the only steam and I want
to make is why am I in Texas and I'm the
only one wearing a bolo tie I don't know
Lari PGA Hill you may cover this in your
book which I've got to read
why did Milton Friedman not favor a gold
standard well
Milton Friedman was of the optimistic
view that we could get a paper money
standard that would be just as sound as
a gold standard and spare us the
resource costs at least thought it was
his view in the 1960s he became a little
more cynical he started to read some
public choice and he realized the Fed
wasn't going to give us sounder money
and in the 1980s he started saying we
need to shut down the Federal Open
Market Committee but he didn't favor
going back to a gold standard then he
favored freezing the monetary base and
letting banks once again issue currency
if the public wanted to hold more or
less currency but I think the thing that
really concerned him was the resource
cost question and he thought that we
could have a paper money that would be
just as sound without having to dig it
out of the ground thank you this was a
really my question is for Brian which is
that you know you said one argument for
going on the gold standard is that it
would you know cause the government to
found to follow better tax policies
print less money basically and also have
better fiscal policy but if the
government were willing to do all that
then you wouldn't need the gold standard
right I mean so the question is are you
putting the cart before the horse here
yeah I mean I just think it's it's
become an inevitable historical
conclusion based on recent history and
surely longer history than that that low
and stable gold correlates with with
with great booms the thing about
government finance I mean if we really
do have a great boom if we grow like we
did in the early Ronald Reagan years
seventeen percent in three years real
terms the government is going to rake in
so much money it's it's it's good it's
not gonna know what to do with it I mean
there'll also be seniority effects you
know coming to be able to print money
and get real resources for return they
could actually lower taxes and just fund
the entire government on the base of
seniority I actually think the United
States could do that the United States
could probably
eliminate taxation and still claim about
one trillion dollars a year in resources
on the basis of printing money so we I
mean we have it within our hands to grow
at phenomenal rates if only would commit
to a low and stable price of gold it's
such a strong correlation that I have to
believe there's causation involved we do
have we do have time for one final
question
my question relates to government's
action if they were willing to keep
their printing of money by constantly
every month putting paper out to bring
mortgages in to help the economy but the
money just piles up in the banks I get
lost on how that helps and if they kept
doing that no matter what standards you
are seems to me you end up in the same
place more currency out there that's not
backed how am I wrong
I mean I'll take one stab at it I mean I
I think it again the real sector is the
most important thing I mean when you
when you have people who are investing
in enterprises that yield profits jobs
that recycle themselves into new more
profitable entities it almost doesn't
matter what the government is doing it
you almost by definition have a good
monetary system so the government should
just de commit from trying to manipulate
the monarchist the monetary system just
quit that and you probably going to have
a booming real sector I actually had a
comment about the gold price I think
it's a little dangerous
first of all fixing the price of gold
that is targeting it using a central
bank central bank's monetary tools to do
so isn't the same as having a gold
standard where people have a contractual
right to convert paper money into gold
that had a definite rate of conversion
and so can discipline the authorities
and prevent them from over issuing them
I'm not I'm not impressed by this tight
correlation of gold and good times I
could show you a similarly tight
correlation of fine weather and furled
umbrellas and thereby conclude that if
we just wouldn't open our umbrellas by
God it would never rain or storm again
and so I think I think there's a real
danger in jumping to the conclusion that
the tightly stability of gold's price is
ipso facto evidence of sound monetary
policy and that goes particularly for
those great booms some of which weren't
so great
all right well thank you very much we're
goign me in in thanking our panel here
[Applause]